[Music]
good evening I'm Bret Baier we are
coming to you tonight from Fox News
world headquarters in New York our top
story is about 250 miles outside
Washington DC one person is dead and a
lot of Republican lawmakers are shaken
up after a train carrying them to a
political retreat hit a truck on the
railroad tracks near the West Virginia
border the Virginia border with West
Virginia several people on board that
train taken to hospitals and naturally
right after it happened
questions started about whether this was
an accident or something else
correspondent Peter Doocy is has the
latest tonight from White Sulphur
Springs West Virginia medium Peter
good evening Bret almost three hours
into a chartered train ride from
Washington DC to West Virginia lawmakers
were jolted they heard a loud noise the
cars quickly screeched from 70 to 0
according to one member and that is
because their ride to a retreat collided
with a garbage truck on the tracks in
the town of Crozet within minutes as a
strong electrical smell filled the
cabins the Capitol Police pleaded with
any physicians on board to administer
first aid to the most seriously injured
and that is when a handful of
legislators turned into lifesavers among
the doctors on board Louisiana Louisiana
Senator Bill Cassidy Ohio congressman
Brad Wenstrup Texas congressman Michael
Burgess Tennessee congressman Phil Roe
and Kansas congressman Roger Marshall
who told us two of the passengers in the
truck required the most urgent attention
but that one could not be saved
dr. Rove and I could not find a pulse
and as I his pupils were fixed and
dilated and thought it was best to call
that code and move all of our attention
back to the first victim five train
passengers were taken to the University
of Virginia hospital for head injuries
including a staffer for House Speaker
Paul Ryan and a representative from
Minnesota congressman Jason Lewis who
was evaluated for a concussion and tells
Fox quote I'm fine compared to
tragically the truck drivers and
thankful for the prompt action of our
doctors and first responders my thoughts
are with the family of the individual
who passed away back in
see meanwhile the president who was
briefed says it's going to be a while
until authorities know how a truck ended
up on the tracks in front of a heavily
guarded train we're going to have a full
understanding yet as to what happened
but it was a train hitting a truck going
at a pretty pretty good speed and we'll
have a full report at the point of
impact the badly damaged engine car was
eventually removed and the remaining
cars were towed backwards to a train
station in downtown Charlottesville
where Republicans were quickly loaded
onto buses for a drive to their planned
retreat
during the disease
somebody just back
[Music]
we were there the transfer from train
cars to buses in Charlottesville was
tense at times because state and local
authorities we're not expecting to have
half of Congress dropped by the middle
of a college town in the middle of the
day lawmakers that I have spoken to are
upset about what happened but they are
here now trying to refocus on their 2018
agenda Bret Peter thank you